today's topic
are me and preach self-made
what's wrong
nah i'm not a fan of that term i already
spoke about that right
we spoke about in the group chat but um
but go ahead i don't like that term yeah
i understand what people mean by that
but i just disagree with the term
i don't disagree with
the whole the phrasing self-made
who is really self-made that'd be a
disrespect to
the people that have my back and be a
disrespect to my wife it'll be this
disrespect to my sister do you [ __ ]
disrespect to you
fair
disrespect that would be [ __ ]
disrespectful to me that's bad [ __ ]
big disrespect to you no but it would be
no i'm self-made [ __ ]
you know what i mean that'd be
disrespectful that would be
disrespectful to you guys you that are
watching that would be a disrespect to
you that'd be a disrespect to my mentors
that'd be a disrespect to my quarter
that'd be a disrespect to all the people
that i look up to i can name names it
wouldn't tell you to you but it's people
that i look up to that i that that that
helped me people that gave me chances
that be disrespected with all of them
self-made
is not
it's it's not accurate and i even have
this conversation with my one of my
mentors mike ward and he told me yeah
but you know
even if i didn't give you the chances
that i gave you you would be able to do
it yes yes you're right if he didn't
give me the chances in the position that
i was able to do to perform what i do i
would still have done it a different way
but you did
you did so let's not talk about yet but
if i didn't you did
so your point isn't valid who is really
self-made yeah
you guys are liking today's video make
sure you like comment okay help us out
with that youtube algorithm there's no
reason not to it's free go so i was on
the no jumper podcast podcast i planned
to do months ago and pretty excited
because i like adam's interview style at
one point we talked about life
circumstances and he's asked like how
does it feel to get here by your own
work and i'm like well
if i'm being honest a lot of the reasons
why i'm here in front of you guys today
some of it is also just due to pure luck
i'm not saying that my forward attitude
didn't contribute but i met the right
people at the right times that really
helped me out and saved my life
a couple wrong decisions going to the
wrong place i might be in prison right
now this is not hyperbolic very serious
sometimes i think people have this whole
like pick yourself up by the bootstraps
you know this person made it from the
worst circumstances so why can't you but
yeah for every one person that makes it
from those terrible circumstances 20
others who tried just as hard but end up
dying or ended up going the wrong way or
try to help the family member for the
wrong decisions and end up in trouble
our environment shapes a lot of our
outcomes in life that's statistically
proven our self-determination also has a
huge impact but the things around us
impact us that's why sometimes you could
be trying your best and you take a
bullet to the leg and your aspirations
are done for circumstances matter if
you've got parents that are abusive and
are malnourishing you sorry but it's
going to impact your body so negatively
that it might kill any athletic career
that you may want to have there's a
reason why people from terrible parent
households oftentimes don't make it out
and have great outcomes in life there's
reason why
people from single-parent households
have far worse outcomes in life you
can't acknowledge that reality and also
say those people inherently didn't work
harder and i'm not going to hear about
people saying like yeah no but i know
people and it doesn't mean that yeah
like he said
for all the people that were able to do
it there's a bunch of people that were
in the same exact position that couldn't
yes just acknowledging those
circumstances matter and i say that
because
if i don't acknowledge that then that
means i'm doing a disservice like preach
said to all the people who helped me out
when it mattered you know when i was
going to do the no jumper podcast i had
the pleasure of going to watch two
mentors of mine who i knew when i was
like 23 right brees lee and jackie from
versus style company all right they were
in a dance company and they're the ones
who kind of really helped me out when i
was living in la they showed me a lot of
love they showed me a lot of information
a lot of places to go to when i had
nothing you told me about it you know
and i had the opportunity to go watch
them perform with their next generation
of dancers that they're cultivating
within that scene in los angeles and it
made me so happy to be able to support
them to be able to be there in person to
watch it and just to reunite with the
people who helped me get to the place i
am today for me to sit here and say i'm
self-made would be
doing such a disservice to people who
were so influential in my life whether
it be the teacher in high school who
said i had way more potential than i was
realizing and that i shouldn't give up
on myself even though i want to drop out
of high school he doesn't realize it he
doesn't even know how he affected me but
hearing those words from him was like
one of the first times ever in my whole
life where someone said you're not a bad
person you got some skills i was like
damn
even though i'm sleeping in your class
every day and i do have decent on your
test you really think that about me
because he was able to see that in me
before i could see them
you know sometimes it's a few words from
people sometimes it's people just
letting you stay at their place uh the
kindness of heart because they want to
help you out you know they've been
different times in my life whether it be
my parents whether you're my siblings
whether it be different folks who help
push me forward and i think when i hear
the term self-made it just sounds so
selfish and it sounds so arrogant
regards to not acknowledging the effort
that everyone else made even my parents
even my parents i couldn't see my like
eye to eye on a lot of things with my
parents but they did help me they didn't
help me with housing they didn't help me
like whenever i had i was i was in a bad
like pass like drop a couple of coins
like on my lab and stuff my mom and my
dad so just me having a mom and a dad
that was willing to do that for me and
they did great for themselves with other
people but they did great it's like yeah
it would be it would be a very
disrespectful to them too yes to be
clear four bees define self made as
someone who built a company or establish
a fortune on their own rather than
inheriting some or all of it but you
inherent things from people you inherit
ideas lessons connections
culture baggage
so the first the first couple of videos
that we were doing were called was
culture yes there's a lot of culture
you inherited from your family in
regards to hating culture that's what we
would cover initially
definitely i got my og's in comedy who
no matter how far ahead i get no matter
how big of a following i'm always gonna
look up to them because when i was
coming up they're the ones who helped me
along
yeah and i think you know it's cool when
you watch anime all the time you always
see the protagonist going up against the
final boss and he's on his last leg and
the boston sim they're fighting tooth
and nail and often times what propels
like the
protagonist forward is like all the
people who are counting on it all the
people who push them forward and support
it or all the ones who sacrifice to get
them to that point and it's like the
reoccurring theme and i think what you
see throughout the world is like that
sense of community and people pushing
you forward is always traditionally true
and so yeah to me i got so many people i
need to thank and to say listen y'all
help me get here so how can i help you
that's one of the biggest joys okay of
being here now i get to help the folks
that help me along the way
i could be like how can i support you
guys on your journeys
that's the best part
i could tell my mom not hers now the way
she helped me my brother my best friends
the people around me who organized
community events and who mentored me i
get to support them now i get to push
them forward the way they did for me
just be mindful of that i don't think
there's anything wrong with working hard
i don't think there's anything wrong
with grinding by yourself that's okay
that's good but don't forget to
acknowledge and appreciate the people
who help you get there if you forget
that then i think you're doing a big
disservice to your roots so yeah and
maybe maybe you know what maybe
i believe that anything can happen maybe
out there there's some people that are
really self-made
i really had nothing nothing maybe
maybe in a couple of circumstances i'm
really talking for myself fair i'm
talking for me
maybe you in your perception you're like
nah b i'm self made none of these
[ __ ] won't maybe maybe that's
your way of seeing it and maybe you are
but for me
if people are asking me the question i'm
i'm just going to go like
that's just not my situation sometimes i
feel like i can't even repay all the
kindness that people showed me so you
pay forward
try to pay it forward
sometimes it's so overwhelming you know
i just try to play it
i just try to pay for the best i can
because i got a lot of people that were
helping me and i got a lot of people
that didn't have necessarily that that
that that help or that luck that i had
so what i'm trying to do is just you
know what i can't repay to my mentor
because he already has what he has right
i can repayment with my loyalty
gratitude gratitude and sometimes
whenever he asks me some questions
guidance sometimes but i can never
really fully repay him what he did and
what he changed for me yeah but so what
i do is i repay it i pay it forward to
other people i help whoever is on my
path and need help you need help you
want to start comedy you want to do this
or that whatever what not i'm going to
be able to help you if i can because i
can yep yeah
yeah so if you guys are doing good by
people sometimes you don't even realize
the ways you might be changing their
lives so you know try to make that
effort to be the kind person to the
people around you to be supportive it
can go a long way you know even just
saying a few words sometimes could be
the difference
so
i'll try to keep that in mind it was
great you should definitely go watch a
verse style show i want to go watch it
was amazing yeah amazing i was really
pleasantly proud i was ready to hate on
them i'm like a dance company whatever
that watch i was like damn this just lit
really yeah what was that this is los
angeles they were doing outdoors last
design
it was in beverly hills the first time
going there yeah i took uber to beverly
hills i'm like is this even legal i'm
driving my passport i belong here i
really felt out of place i was walking
around beverly hills and everyone was
just walking around and don't get me
wrong the people who in the audience
were really cool but i just remember
being like around that much money i was
like yeah yeah i'm not supposed because
i've driven through beverly hills to get
to ucla but i never actually stopped
there so it's just my fault something
different yeah it was different but um
sometimes they get they do mostly shows
in the inner city or they'll do it at
schools and stuff like that but this
time they were invited to go do it at
that at a really nice venue and uh the
show was great the show was great and i
got to see him after when you don't see
someone from a long time
but you got so much love for them and
you're like yo come here you know what
i'm saying
give it give me here you know what i'm
saying
because like
it's one of the cool things about
getting older and also kind of one of
the sad things at the same time
but you can see other people around you
age
and you get to realize just how much
history you have i mean
i've known these people for almost one
third of my life that's a long time
you know and just to see them doing good
and see that they're progressing just to
see them period you're just turning and
understanding like what they did for you
when they didn't have to because i had
nothing to give them yeah but they still
did it they just did it it's like
let me show you some of something
sometimes you think about growing old is
you you see yourself going maturing you
know you're seeing yourself going from a
kid
to a boy to a man
to a book
and you become a book you become a book
of knowledge to other people around you
and that's what you can give to other
people your knowledge you become a book
in the shelf of life or whatever you
want to call it but that's what it is is
that our og's our books it's books you
can read that's why you need to talk to
your og's you need to talk to your old
people to see not necessarily take
everything that they give you because
you know sometimes it you know
times change and [ __ ] yeah but it's good
to talk to old books
[Music]
it's not like an insult but it's really
what it is there's that famous quote
that's when an old person dies alive
yeah and i think it's it's so accurate
so i get it you always want to show
appreciation and love sometimes like
[ __ ] can i just send you on a vacation
yeah yeah stop being a book for today go
be a tourist go yo go go live your life
go live your goddamn live girls that
time man close that book go back to that
bag let me send you back there like you
used to send me as a child yes yeah you
want to go back i'll pay first class go
back to africa let me take you back to
ethiopia because you're people not like
their people saying go back go back
that was my mom's number one threat i'll
send you back i'll send you back earlier
yeah and then she sent me back yeah
that's haiti yeah she sent me back
though
she did she sent me back he did yeah i'm
gonna take you out like whatever
whatever
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i'm there is that a
giraffe okay it's like [ __ ] well you're
here for the summer did you get [ __ ]
wearing sweatpants and holding the ak-47
that's crazy is this standard military
uniform
sandals didn't fubuka all ten years ago
flip-flops and military
that's a good podcast name
flip flopping a case
[Music]
you guys are liking today's video make
sure you like comment okay help us out
with that youtube algorithm there's no
reason not to it's free
go hey you call it that i call it
standard military retire
the rebel forces
that's it for uh today's topic i want to
just talk about this if you guys want
you go check out the new jumper
interview there was some cool stuff
which was some really cool yours of mine
well both of them apparently yeah yeah
because i went to watch yours i said
[ __ ]
you trying to make somebody cry
yeah yeah it was what it was but yeah
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below do you guys have anybody
that you feel grateful and if you do let
them know
go let them know how much they mean to
you and how much they've helped you out
i promise you don't mean a lot to them
okay and yeah breeze and jackie if y'all
watching this
holla at you what's good
[Music]
so thank you very much for watching the
video this was versa style dance
company's weekly community classes
5.18 and under 10 19 and over cheapest
classes you're going to find in l.a some
of the best classes you're going to find
in l.a so much more than just dance what
we try to represent we try to represent
family that spirituality that foundation
that group that dance it's all about
heart for us versus style so once again
thank you for watching thank you to our
boy abba for filming it's been a
pleasure man and we will see you on
friday peace
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]